leaving the embassy for who knows how
long france's ambassador to australia
stopped his car for a few words to
reporters i think this has been a huge
mistake a very very bad
handling of partnership because it was
not a contract it was a partnership
a trusted partnership that's supposed to
be based on trust mutual understanding
and also a partnership based
you know on sincerity
you'll see is a result you speak french
then it was to sydney airport for his
flight home
empty of its ambassador too is the
french embassy in washington dc this is
an unprecedented move by france the
united states oldest ally
you have to go back to before the first
president of the united states that's
george washington here to find the
origins of this alliance between france
and the us
just two years after the us declaration
of independence in 1778 france formally
recognized the strange new nation and
then backed it in its war against the
british in all of the years since then
this is the first time says the french
foreign ministry it's ever recalled its
ambassador to the u.s
it's proof of how angry france is right
now and this is why
and so friends august is born
a new enhanced trilateral security
partnership between australia the united
kingdom and the united states
on wednesday australia the uk and the us
unveiled orcas it's a defense agreement
aimed at countering china in the
indo-pacific
but it cuts france out of a 2016 deal to
build diesel power submarines for
australia in favor of nuclear-powered
tech from the uk and us
it'll leave france tens of billions of
dollars poorer and it's being seen by
paris as a gross deception by friends
and allies still there are those who
think paris is overreacting
i think you know
it was not necessary i mean we have
never recalled
previously our ambassador from
washington
and it's
really very bad manners
from the americans to
towards france i mean really america has
been treating macron like an underdog
and so on but
it's only bad manners
and i think that vengeance
is a meal that should be served cold
as for the uk well france has spared
london the sting of pulling home its
ambassador instead french ministers have
tried something more withering they
suggest it's not worth bothering with
junior partners and that's all the uk is
to the us
rory helens al jazeera london